let's try our caller from the five seven
zero area code who's calling today from
five seven zero Jordan from Pennsylvania
hey Jordan what's going on well there's
a was anger about censorship online
social media and I thought about
something that the government plums the
road the government funds the library
right another social services why can't
they fun the public access Internet its
non-commercial something so on you're
protected by law some places have it and
you can what I can't do a national thing
and that's why take the place of YouTube
you're confusing two things now so
YouTube is a platform not not an
Internet service provider a and by the
way I'm hearing my own voice echoing
back so if I'm on speaker please please
please take me off are you talking about
the government running a social media
platform or the government running the
internet utility oh okay
I don't know that I see the advantage of
the government necessarily running the
social platform although it's an
interesting idea but there are places
like for example out in western
Massachusetts near where the show
started there's a place called Leverett
and Leverett and maybe it's shoots berry
maybe it's both they're really small
places so they're not that interesting
for like Comcast to come into but they
have municipal broadband they have
established municipal broadband services
that the town owns it it's cheaper than
what a lot of the for-profit companies
provide that's super interesting to me I
guess I haven't given much thought to
the government like a government
Facebook or YouTube I don't know that
I'd have to think more about that but
the government getting involved in
running some of these utilities or at
least the regulation of these utility of
these Internet service providers as
utilities which is part of net
neutrality ideas that is very important
and I would be very much supportive of
that yeah because there's a lot of
anonymous people harassing and people
are trying to make a quick dollar and I
think internet would be better to the
intellectual that you start really there
but are you saying you you
all websites to be run by the government
I mean it's it sounds a little a little
crazy no you would have an option you
can either you know go to the public
library or go to the bookstore and pay
yeah you're cool so there would be
internet where the content is run by the
government and then another Internet
where people can put up the stuff they
want yeah
regulated by the government you're
protected by the First Amendment
yeah something like a public exit no I
don't know that it totally works but
because you know there's already
websites that are run by all sorts of
people governments and individuals but
the municipal broadband piece is really
important and I'm very much behind that
appreciate the phone call thank you very
much I hope to hear from you again